this video is sponsored by ag1 save $20
when you subscribe using the link in the
description as a child you're filled
with enthusiasm and sensitivity the
world is small and your eyes are big but
as you grow older everything gets bigger
and you stay mostly the same size give
or take a few feet the chaos the
complexity and the impossible obscurity
of the world surround and overtake you
as your sense of significance and
security shrinks down to a tiny pinpoint
you continue on following the course you
do things you accomplish things you
obtain things but nothing ever solves it
that panging dis quiet unrest and
desolation you keep finding yourself in
the same place no matter how hard you
try or how far you run loved ones die
Hearts break horrible things happen you
realize more and more the horrible
things that could and will happen
everything becomes a faded backdrop to
the unrelenting problems of the
day-to-day
eventually you learn how to deal with it
you become numb indifferent you make
sure nothing can really affect you it
wasn't a conscious decision you don't
remember making it at least life Hur to
touch and so naturally you stopped
holding on to it so tightly now nothing
much affects you but you don't feel much
of
anything it isn't quite apathy in the
traditional sense at least it's not
quite depression it's something else
something in between or outside of these
terms it isn't a feeling like you're
stuck in quicksand but more like the
feeling of just okayness while sitting
on the White Sands of a beautiful beach
you still function mostly fine you still
get out of bed get things done pursue
goals achieve things engage with the
world but it all feels more
automatic things you used to love to do
you might still do but they don't feel
the same or perhaps you don't do them at
all anymore and you haven't found a
replacement
you don't have much of a social life
anymore but you're okay with that you
still go places and do things and know
when things are nice but the awareness
of this is often more intellectual than
visceral achievements don't feel
conclusively great but more like
shortlived breaks from the pain of the
failures you still keep going at nearly
full speed but you aren't sure why or
for what perhaps you've been here for a
while perhaps you've just found yourself
here whatever the case may be firstly
it's arguably important to recognize
that this is a natural and likely
inevitable stop on a life that has
passed through enough years enough real
moments enough exposure and reflection a
life that contains enough inbuilt
sensitivity but of course this is not a
great place to
stay like how a callus on part of the
hand can serve a useful purpose a
reduction of sensitivity to a particular
area that's been frequently irritated a
degree of a kind of indifference and
apathy toward the uncontrollable irrit
ating and terrible aspects of life can
be useful if not essential in many
seminal schools of philosophy like
stoicism Daoism and Buddhism a central
principle is to embrace a kind of
indifference to or Detachment from
reality from the perspective of the
stoics it is important to distinguish
what one can control from what one
cannot and then exhibit a sort of
indifference or tempered concern and
response toward what one cannot which is
essentially everything outside of
oneself to Bear trials with a Calm Mind
robs Misfortune of its strength and
burden stoic philosopher senica wrote In
the case of dosm a central tenant is to
give up the attempt to control things by
practicing a sort of non-action from the
perspective of Buddhism and perhaps also
from a more modern Western parallel
philosophical pessimism life is
fundamentally suffering and the way to
overcome suffering is through
non-attachment or transcending the
condition of the Mind by ending its
Relentless attachment to worldly
concerns and desires I ironically
similar to what senica said while
simultaneously suggesting a very
different sentiment pessimus philosopher
Emil Tron wrote having always lived in
fear of being surprised by the worst I
have tried in every circumstance to get
a head start flinging myself into
Misfortune long before it
occurred whether we agree with any or
all of these philosophies or these
individual ideas within them there is
undoubtedly some Merit and
reasonableness to applying a degree of
Detachment or indifference to certain
aspects of life but a whole other
problem occurs when we take it too far a
hand entirely calloused over makes it
hard to feel anything with sensitivity
hard to experience and discern the
details of things the softness of skin
of fabric of the sand of a beautiful
beach in truth we often build a castle
when we only need a shield the pendulum
swings all the way over into the realm
of apathetic stuper and then it can
often just stop swinging altogether
because perhaps the most dangerous part
of apathy is that one of its side
effects is not caring much about its
side
effects however if you want to get rid
of or reduce a callous on the hand you
have to stop doing the same thing with
your hand and then give it time for the
callous to go away likewise if one wants
to reduce the callous nature of on you
have to at least partly stop doing the
same thing with yourself with your life
and then give it time to go away this
could involve partly changing how you
live dayto day adding activities Hobbies
challeng lunches or people or perhaps
changing or eliminating activities
Hobbies or people or rather it could
involve changing how you think about
things uncovering a new framework or
Paradigm of perception and a way of
interfacing with the world or it could
be a combination of both or something
else of course no matter what it is it
won't be easy finding one's way out of a
state in which one has lost a notable
amount of care or feeling requires a
certain amount of care or feeling that
one might no longer easily have access
to at least not right now but perhaps
Alber Kimu said it best when he wrote in
the middle of winter I at last
discovered that there was in me an
invincible
summer ultimately life moves in Seasons
we can't always be energized or excited
or principally in tune with the good we
can't always be warm and welcoming we
can't always be bright and exuding with
life but like the snow covered soil
underneath a wintry landscape still has
the ability to produce new life with the
changing of seasons
so too do you still have the ability to
Foster New Life in time you still have
your internal World your faculties your
perspective your creativity and your
ability to adapt and endure if you
weren't always here you likely won't
always be and even if you are you'll
still adapt and you'll be okay whether
it's in seasons of struggle or one
lifelong experience of the coldness of
the universe through your perspective
and individual choices you could still
provide yourself with comfort with
meaning with the warmth of invincible
fortitude perhaps all we have is this
the Invincible summer inside of
ourselves but perhaps that's all we'll
ever
need this video was sponsored by H1
Mental Health and Wellness in general
are very complex there's no simple
solution no one size fits all but there
are of course foundational building
blocks that are essential of across the
board one of them which we all know but
still so easily Overlook in neglect is
our nutrition it's actually unsettling
how much our gut health can affect our
mental and emotional experience of the
day-to-day ag1 is a daily foundational
nutrition supplement that supports whole
body Health including the brain the gut
and the immune system and it does all of
this with one drink one of the hardest
parts of getting daily nutrition is
dealing with the nuisance of it all
different supplements different dietary
requirements and so on I've been
drinking ag1 on a daily basis for nearly
a year now and it completely eliminates
this problem it makes it simple and
convenient and compacts everything into
one easy habit it tastes great and it's
the perfect way to start the day on the
right foot supporting sustained energy
and improved mood throughout the day as
well as supporting overall health in
general over the long term ag1 does this
through its science-driven blend of pre
and probiotics digestive enzymes plant
extracts antioxidants high quality
ingredients like riola magnesium and B
vitamins and so much more especially
during the holiday season managing
stress and supporting your digestion are
essential and beginning the new year
with a habit in place that gives your
mind and body The Edge to move forward
into feeling better is of course one of
the best things you can do and thanks to
ag1 now it's one of the easiest save $20
when you subscribe at drink a1.com
pursuit of Wonder H1 is also offering a
free one-year supply of AG vitamin D3
and K2 and five travel packs with your
first purchase using my link which is in
the description and as always thank you
so much for watching in general and see
you next
[Music]
video